[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
de la actualidad africana Mi nombre es
amal bentman comenzamos con los
titulares
500 muertos y 58 violaciones más de un
año después de la incursión del ejército
maliense en el pueblo de mora en el
centro de Mali la ONU ha publicado un
informe devastador sobre lo ocurrido
tenemos análisis un acuerdo para la
apertura de corredores humanitarios en
Sudán los emisarios de los dos generales
enfrentados firmaron el documento en
Jetta Arabia Saudita pero mientras los
combates siguen asolando el país el
texto no prevé ninguna tregua la quinta
edición de Muecas Está celebrando en
Colombia la programación de este
festival que promueve producciones
cinematográficas africanas incluye
varios largometrajes y cortometrajes así
como documentales y películas de
animación
director del evento es nuestro invitado
empezamos en Mali la ONU lo ha
confirmado el ejército de este país y
militares extranjeros al parecer
mercenarios rusos del grupo paramilitar
Wagner ejecutaron a cientos de civiles
en mura una localidad del centro del
país los hechos ocurrieron entre el 27
el 31 de marzo del año pasado durante
una incursión en la zona En aquel
momento medios de comunicación y
organizaciones de derechos humanos y ya
habían denunciado la masacre ahora
corroborada por las Naciones Unidas en
un informe hecho público tras varios
meses de espera
hablamos con José Naranjo periodista
especialista en la región del zagel nos
explicó cómo determinaron las fuerzas
armadas malienses quien era yadista y
quien no antes de llevar a cabo las
matanzas
Pues bien esta estos militares tenían
Aparentemente una lista con las
identidades de las personas a las que
estaban buscando
y no la las encontraban entonces lo que
ocurrió es que a todos aquellos
que tenían abro comillas una apariencia
yihadista cierro comillas
los iban interrogando los acusaban de
complicidad o directamente de ser
yihadista y los ejecutaban algunos de
ellos a muchos de ellos no de manera
sumaria sin juicio ni nada y en les
disparaban y los enterraban en fosas
comunes o los dejaban simplemente en el
pueblo según los testimonios recogidos
por Naciones Unidas
varios testimonios indicaron que los
milicianos extranjeros presentes junto a
las fuerzas armadas de Mali eran
mercenarios del grupo Wagner pero el
informe de la ONU no lo dice continuamos
con el análisis de José Naranjo
respecto a la presencia de Wagner hay
una enorme controversia dado que
numerosos testimonios efectivamente
tanto desde Mali como desde los
servicios de inteligencia occidentales
de Estados Unidos y de numerosos países
europeos hablan de la presencia
del Wagner de hecho de cientos de
mercenarios de Wagner en Mali que han
ido además ocupando estas bases
militares que los franceses han ido
dejando a raíz de sus rectificada o de
su expulsión
y parece que es un hecho en fin
contrastado por muchas Fuentes el
informe de Naciones Unidas se retrasó
mucho para publicarse porque existieron
presiones de alto nivel en el propio
seno de Naciones Unidas hay que recordar
que Rusia está en el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas no entonces
bueno esas presiones existieron ese y de
hecho es un informe que que se publicó
con muchos meses de retraso ha tardado
un año y dos meses cuando la
investigación estaba terminada hace
meses el informe menciona también casos
de violencia sexual y de tortura la
organización amnistía internacional
pidió la intervención de la Corte Penal
Internacional el especialista nos
comentó también Cuál es el margen de
maniobra de los organismos
internacionales
digamos que las dificultades para que se
lleve a cabo una investigación son
enormes
y Mientras esté gobernando la junta
militar va difícil va a ser difícil que
se lleve adelante un proceso tendrá que
hablar la Corte Penal Internacional
tendrán que hablar las autoridades
o sea los organismos de derechos humanos
y ver de qué manera se puede llevar a
los perpetradores de esta ante la
justicia pero quiero recordar mura es la
Escandalosa sin duda Pero solo la punta
del verde muchas otras masacres que se
están cometiendo en este momento es mal
y también en burkina faso hace muy
poquito tuvimos la masacre de karma por
ejemplo en burkina faso en el que
supuestamente
Soldados del ejército de urquino falso
también asesinaron a decenas de personas
quiero decir lo que está pasando en el
es de una gravedad enorme y creo que no
hay una conciencia muy clara en
occidente de la gravedad de los hechos a
mí me ha sorprendido la escasa presencia
mediática por ejemplo de este informe de
Naciones Unidas sí se ha publicado pero
creo que Tendría que haber ocupado un
mayor espacio mediático no pero esto nos
habla una vez más de la discriminación
mediática de África
y por su parte la junta mallence
denunció el informe y lo calificó de
documento falso basado en un relato
ficticio según las autoridades malienses
ningún civil murió durante la operación
militar
continuamos en Sudán mientras los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército
sudanés y las fuerzas paramilitares de
apoyo rápido siguen representantes de
las partes beligerantes firmaron un
acuerdo en Jetta Arabia Saudita sobre la
apertura de corredores para permitir que
los civiles abandonen las zonas de
combate y que llegue la ayuda
humanitaria veamos un acuerdo
humanitario pero ninguna tregua
emisarios del ejército sudanés y
representantes de las fuerzas
paramilitares de apoyo rápido firmaron a
buena distancia un acuerdo de principio
en lleva Arabia Saudita
seis días de negociaciones fueron
necesarios para alcanzar este texto que
prevé la apertura de corredores para
permitir la salida de civiles de las
zonas de combate y la llegada de ayuda
humanitaria
pero el cese de las hostilidades
esperado por muchos no fue alcanzado
los combates que comenzaron hace un mes
entre los antiguos aliados continúan y
millones de sudaneses principalmente en
jartum permanecen atrincherados en sus
casas Sobreviviendo Al sofocante Calor
sin agua corriente ni electricidad
enérgicamente esta violencia gratuita en
la que ambas partes han pisoteado el
derecho internacional humanitario
Especialmente los principios de
distinción proporcionalidad y precaución
los enfrentamientos han dejado casi mil
muertos y alrededor de un millón de
desplazados y refugiados según las
últimas cifras oficiales
pasamos ahora a otro tema La Quinta
edición del festival de cine africano
muy caa comenzado en Colombia y este
evento itinerante tiene lugar en varias
ciudades del país y dura todo el mes de
mayo para más detalles estamos con el
director del evento
Gracias por estar con nosotros Muchas
gracias amal siempre un placer estar
aquí en el estudio de África siete días
Qué le parece empezar con el tráiler del
festival perfecto empecemos por ahí
vamos a verlo veamos el tráiler del
evento
[Música]
el programa de esta nueva edición es muy
abundante han incluido ustedes novedades
con respecto a las ediciones anteriores
Claro que sí de eso se trata la música
siempre de innovar un poco y en esta
ocasión tenemos dos adiciones muy
especiales con respecto a cortometrajes
tenemos dos cortometrajes del Caribe de
uno de Haití y uno de Guadalupe y
sentimos que esto es una región que está
muy poco representada en los festivales
cinematográficos tanto en Colombia como
en la región en general sabemos muy poco
de la producción cinematográfica del
Caribe incluso qué festivales hay allá
Pero además de eso tenemos algunas
alianzas con entidades africanas que es
parte también de la fortaleza de la
wicca tenemos por ejemplo una alianza
con el festival pisahara que es el
festival de Derechos Humanos
en esa hora occidental y también una
alianza con generation África que es una
colección de 25 documentales sobre
migración dirigidos por cineastas
africanos de manera que por fin la
migración se está contando desde África
y no a través de las Voces del Norte
global digamos tenemos tres títulos de
esta colección y además de eso tenemos
un gran clásico africano un dirigido por
usman el padre en cine africano un
clásico que se llama que ha sido
recientemente restaurado Y tenemos
además para anunciar otra Alianza con
Magic carpet Studios que es un estudio
de animación de Nigeria con los cuales
estamos presentando dos títulos de
animación
Y cómo cómo se hizo la selección de las
películas
bueno la selección de las películas de
la muñeca es una parte muy ardua del
trabajo que hacemos y también una parte
muy placentera hay que decirlo tenemos
que ver muchísimas películas y se trata
de una selección muy estudiada con mucho
rigor que tenga sobre todo diversidad
diversidad de épocas diversidad de
géneros diversidad narrativa diversidad
de países desde la ficción al documentar
el cortometraje el largometraje Y en
este sentido también vemos que la
curaduría de este año pasa desde la
futurismo y de las de la ciencia ficción
hasta los clásicos del cine africano
como decía pasando también por los
Derechos Humanos pasando por la
animación de manera que es una riqueza
que muy rara vez se ve y que queremos
darle al público colombiano
y la película
es la que inauguró el festival nos puede
hablar de esta obra por qué esta obra
bueno esta película sentimos que es una
película que rompe rompe moldes
discursivos a muchos niveles una
película que usa el afofuturismo y la
ciencia ficción y también el género del
musical cinematográfico para hacer una
crítica social una anticolonial para
hablar de la explotación de los recursos
minerales en África de la explotación de
los trabajadores que trabajan en las
minas también es un comentario sobre el
sobre la identidad de género en la
diversidad de género entonces sentimos
que es una película que
que aglomera muchos de estos puntos que
queremos tratar a través de la música no
se trata solamente de realidades o de
expresiones artísticas digamos sino que
esto tenga un componente social que es
muy importante y por supuesto además
esta película viene de la mano de dos
directores que es una pareja creativa
increíble uno Saúl Williams es un músico
sobre todo un poeta y actor
afroamericano de Nueva York y su pareja
creativa y pareja sentimentales que es
la directora de fotografía codirectora
de la película que se ha ganado
muchísimos premios y ella es
efectivamente de Ruanda
Sí y volvemos al festival Cuáles son los
temas de los debates de las charlas de
las conferencias que van a acompañar el
evento este año bueno como siempre Y
como te imaginarás son muy diversas
porque van de la mano de la diversidad
de películas pero este año vamos a
hablar de la ética periodística tanto en
los procesos independentistas de África
como la importancia del periodismo en
los movimientos sociales esto lo vamos a
ver muy ligado a la realidad colombiana
también temas de Derechos Humanos temas
de migración y por supuesto un elemento
que es muy importante para nosotros
habitualmente es la música se trata de
conectar la música las expresiones
artísticas de África con las de Colombia
y América Latina en general y fortalecer
ese puente reconocernos también como
espejo como regiones que artísticamente
siempre estamos alimentándonos
mutuamente perfecto salir Muchas gracias
por estar en África siete días Muchas
gracias
y gracias a ustedes por seguirnos en la
actualidad internacional continúa en
Francia
[Música]